hey 42 here when it comes to cracking
unsolved mysteries or hunting down
fugitives from justice
you'd have to go a long way to beat the
fbi
agent clara stalling for instance dealt
admirably with hannibal lecter
and mulder and scully solved all manner
of annoying supernatural and
extraterrestrial problems
but it's unlikely even these fictional
heavyweights would have been able to
solve
the strange case of db cooper a mystery
that's bamboozled the feds
for over four decades and to this day
still seems
about as solvable as a sudoku puzzle
printed on a rubik's cube
designed by mensa on the day before
thanksgiving in 1971 whilst most
decent u.s citizens were getting ready
to force sage and onion up the nearest
turkey's anus
a gentleman by the name of dan cooper
approached the flight desk for
northwest orient airlines bought a
one-way ticket from portland to seattle
paid cash and boarded the boeing 727
heading towards his scheduled
destination
due to the holidays the flight was only
a third fault so
cooper took a seat at the rear of the
plane ordered a bourbon and soda
and made himself comfortable if db
cooper's still alive today then
i'm pretty sure he subscribes to bespoke
post bespoke post is a fantastic
monthly subscription box that's tailored
to you
bespoke posts find out exactly what you
like whether that's
bar ware apparel outdoor gear
and every month you get a box full of
that stuff that you love
so they've sent over a box and i'm
really excited to see what's inside
let's have a look in box number one
so what's this oh that's really cool
it's sent over instructions on
how to start a fire which i'll be honest
i'll probably need
and then a starter stone first up we
have this
really nice knife made in sweden i do
like swedish knives
i know that's a strange thing to say but
they make they make good knives
that's that's really nice a trifold
candle shovel to shovel i mean
supposed to digging a ship in basically
and it falls up
that's nice this is really nice stuff
it's
really nice that's lovely i'm gonna get
a lot of use out of this
this is fantastic for me because next
time i go camping i can bring something
more practical than just
a bottle of whiskey love this let's see
what we've got in the second box here
oh nice what's this
oh look at that
that is beautiful remember these boxes
are 45
each there's easily over 70 worth of
value here
this feels top quality really does
i'm really looking forward to using this
and right now you can get 20
off your first box if you head to
bspk.meforwardslash42
and use code 4020 at checkout
use the link in the description don't
miss it guys
by this point flight attendant florence
schaffner
hadn't noticed anything unusual about
cooper
after all this was the 1970s so she had
a great deal of experience
ignoring nondescript whiskey-soaked
businessmen
especially if they were making unwelcome
advances towards her
which is exactly what seemed to be
happening just after takeoff
when cooper handed her a note assuming
it was his phone number
florence dropped it into her purse
unread no doubt giving cooper one of
those
in your dreams kind of looks but before
she had a chance to turn away
cooper leaned forward and calmly
explained that
she'd probably best take a look at the
note because it contains some
handy information about the bomb he'd
bought on board
cooper then asked florence to take a
seat next to him and she
quickly complied but only on the proviso
she could see the bomb
first which must have been standard
procedure when faced with a hijacker
either that or she planned on asking him
to stir it safely in the overhead
compartment
cooper opened his briefcase revealing
eight red cylinders and a mess of wires
connected to a large battery
florence didn't know too much about
bombs but she didn't have to
this thing looked like something wiley
coyote might carry around in a warner
brothers cartoon
you could probably order them from acme
cooper's demands
were simple he wanted two hundred
thousand dollars in
negotiable american currency four
parachutes
and a truck ready to refuel a plane when
it arrived in seattle
florence now thoroughly convinced she
wouldn't be getting an early finish for
thanksgiving
headed to the cockpit to completely ruin
pilot william scott's day
we don't have a record of her exact
words but
i assume it was something like this hey
will we've got a hijacker
massive bomb in his briefcase
could i get you a coffee scott
immediately contacted ground control at
seattle tacoma airport
who in turn contacted the authorities
and the plane was forced to stay in the
air for an extra two hours
to give the police and fbi time to
secure the ransom and find the
parachutes
like a true professional however scots
kept the other passengers at ease
claiming the delay was due to a minor
technical difficulty
and if a bomb carrying weirdo was a
minor technical difficulty
you can only imagine what scott must
have considered a major one
extraterrestrial attack godzilla in the
flight path
the entire plane suddenly disintegrating
anyway when cooper's demands had finally
been met the plane finally landed at
seattle tacoma airport
and the rear door was open so florence's
colleague tina muklow
could take delivery of the four
parachutes along with a knapsack stuffed
full of cash
cooper then told florence senior flight
attendant alice hancock
and all the other passengers to exit the
plane
leaving only himself tina muklow flight
engineer harold anderson
pilot william scott and co-pilot william
rataksak on board
apparently you were only allowed to
become a pilot if your name was william
in those days
whilst they were refueling cooper made
some very specific
and slightly odd demands of the flight
crew
he informed them they'd not only be
heading towards mexico city
at the lowest possible speed but also
that he wanted the cabin to remain
unpressurized the wing flaps to be
lowered 15 degrees
and the landing gear to remain deployed
after several objections based around
safety
or the distinct lack of it the plane was
back in the air again by 7 40 pm
headed for mexico city the pilots had
mentioned they'd need to stop in reno
nevada
for more fuel before reaching mexico but
cooper seemed pretty easygoing about
this
slight change in plans weird eh it was
almost as if
he wasn't planning to get that far as
soon as they were airborne cooper told
the remaining crew to head for the
cockpit
and close the door and that's exactly
what they did until around 8pm
when a warning light suddenly came on
indicating
the rear door had been opened sure
enough
not long after this at around 8 13 pm
the tail of the plane suddenly darted
upwards suggesting
something or someone had just left the
cabin
and with that the man known as d.b
cooper passed into legend
when they landed in reno at around 10 15
p.m
the police and fbi conducted an armed
search of the cabin
only to find it had been left like an
aviation themed game of pluto
rather than a candlestick a rope or a
piece of lead piping however
they found a black clip-on tie a
mother-of-pearl tie clip
eight cigarette butts two of the four
parachutes
and around 66 fingerprints which
ultimately proved no matches
unlike the suspect for a grizzly country
house murder however
cooper had all the hallmarks of a
gentleman thief
the crew had nothing but good things to
say about him after the ordeal
and florence described him as calm
polite
and well spoken in fact if it hadn't
been for the whole
bomb in a briefcase thing maybe things
really could have worked out between
them
he certainly wasn't your average
hijacker
florence and tina gave practically
identical descriptions of cooper
mid 40s around 5 foot 10 piercing brown
eyes
and slightly dark skin as did everyone
else who interacted with him
so the fbi had always been very
confident in their accuracy of their
composite sketches
the crew also mentioned he had a
nondescript accent which
could suggest he was american but then
he also used the phrase
negotiable american currency which isn't
the kind of thing
u.s citizen would typically say so
which other nationalities sound slightly
american
could cooper have been canadian
unfortunately nobody got to know him
well enough to find out if he was
pathologically friendly and had a punch
on for ice hockey
but there was one other clue pointing
towards him being canadian
the fbi would later suggest his alias
had come from belgium comic book hero
dan cooper a canadian air force pilot
who had many brave and exciting
adventures
often including parachuting the comic
was never on sale in the us
but it was available in canada by the
way you've probably noticed that
although the hijacking is often referred
to as
the mystery of db cooper at no point did
the mysterious dan cooper actually use
that middle initial
the fbi did interview someone by that
name in the early days of the case
but a journalist rushing to meet a
deadline simply confused the suspect's
name
with the hijackers alias and the db
part stuck whatever his real name might
have been
one question above all others
desperately needed answering
how the hell were we going to find him
pinpointing where cooper may have landed
was going to be
about as easy as finding a piece of
straw in a whole stack full of needles
the fbi were confident about the time
cooper had jumped
after staging a recreation where a
200-pound sled was pushed through the
rear door of the plane
they measured the same upwards tail
motion experienced during the flight
but what happened after he left the
plane
was a bit more tricky to nail down five
fighter jets had been secretly deployed
to follow cooper's flight
but none of them saw him jump which is
understandable given visibility was poor
cooper was dressed in black and by that
point it was completely dark
there were also a lot of other variables
to consider
the precise speed of the plane the
environmental conditions
the amount of time spent in free fall
before pulling the rip cord
if any of these estimates were even
slightly off it would drastically change
the fbi search area after much number
crunching a search began
in clark and cowlitz counties
specifically the areas immediately north
and south of the lewis river in
southwest washington
and over the next few months the fbi
conducted aerial searches
went through mountains with a
fine-toothed comb knocked on the door of
every farmhouse in the area
and even called in a submarine to search
the 200 foot depths
of nearby lake merwin just in case
cooper's corpse
happened to be hiding at the bottom that
might sound optimistic but there had
always been an element of doubt as
to whether cooper survived the jump not
to mention whether he'd been able to
navigate the mountainous terrain
in winter with a briefcase full of cash
instead of a survival kit
on the other hand the fbi couldn't find
anyone who'd gone missing that weekend
suggesting cooper either had no friends
or relatives
or had survived and simply gone back to
his normal life
also in 1978 a deer hunter
near castle rock washington which was on
cooper's flight path
found discarded instructions on how to
lower the rear stairs
of a boeing 727 the very same type of
aircraft cooper had hijacked
coincidence maybe but unless
deer ever start hijacking planes it's
probably worth considering
as legitimate evidence despite not
seeming to have the necessary equipment
for conditions on the ground
it's probably safe to assume cooper had
something planned for the time after his
jump
because it was clear from the get-go
this whole operation had been carried
out
with meticulous attention to detail
for starters it was certainly no
coincidence cooper chose to hijack
a 727-100 he knew the plane was able to
fly at low altitude without stalling
and that the wing flap should be lowered
to 15 degrees for such a maneuver
something that was completely unique to
that specific
aircraft not only that he knew the rear
staircase could be lowered during the
flight
via a switch at the rear of the cabin
which was something never even disclosed
to the flight crew
he also seemed to be very specific about
his parachutes
demanding civilian models rather than
military ones
and the fact he asked for four suggested
he was playing mind games with the fbi
you see if they thought he might be
taking hostages with him on the jump
they were a lot less likely to send him
faulty equipment
or at least you'd hope so whilst
figuring out
exactly where db cooper came down was an
almost insurmountable challenge the fbi
did have
one other way to track cooper the money
they'd recorded the serial number of
each and every bill
and sent lists to casinos race tracks
and any other place they could think of
where cooper might go to
blow a large watch of cash northwest
orient offered a reward for anyone who
could recover the money
as did some local newspapers but
nothing ever showed up until 1980 that
is
when eight-year-old brian ingram
uncovered three packets of ransom cash
on the banks of the columbia river
nine miles south of vancouver washington
the fbi confirmed they were the genuine
article
which must have been quite exciting for
young brian although not half as
exciting as finding out
he could keep half the loot in 2008 he
sold
15 of those 20 bills for 37
000 i suppose that's inflation for you
so who the hell was dan cooper do we
have any
idea well by the five year anniversary
of the hijacking the fbi had considered
more than 800 suspects but there are a
few
fan favorites still being investigated
by
amateur cooper detectives even today
[Music]
one name that keeps cropping up again
and again
is robert rackstraw who was the topic of
the 2016 tv series
db cooper case closed the fbi questioned
him in the 70s and
soon ruled him out but a cold case team
led by former fbi agents
are very keen on this theory indeed
providing a great deal of evidence in
their book
the last master outlaw hmm sounds like
victimization to me
the fbi did originally rule him out
after all
and it isn't like he was a bad guy or
anything
i mean sure he was dismissed from the
army for lying about his rank
and yes there was that time he was
arrested for stealing dynamite
oh and he was charged with the murder of
his own stepfather
and i'm pretty sure he faked his own
death by crushing the stolen plane
but apart from all that he wasn't that
bad
of course he did also phone several news
stations from prison
claiming to be db cooper but that's just
a minor detail
another popular suspect is richard floyd
mccoy
a mormon sunday school teacher and
former green beret
he was tracked down by the fbi for a
cooper copycat hijacking
only five months after cooper struck
he parachuted out over utah with five
hundred thousand dollars and ransom
money
but he was arrested two days later and
given 45 years in prison
he did manage to escape two years later
by crashing the lorry through the prison
gate
but freedom didn't last long he was
killed in a gunfight with the fbi three
months later
mccoy certainly wasn't the first or last
criminal to be inspired by cooper
as if the fbi didn't already have enough
on their plate there were no fewer than
15 cooper copycats during 1972
alone all of them either using bombs or
guns
demanding large sums of money and
escaping via parachute
the major difference between them and db
however
was that they were all found arrested or
sometimes just plain old killed
garrett brock trapnil for instance
demanded over three hundred thousand
dollars in cash
the release of political activist angela
davis
and an audience with president richard
nixon but in the end he had to settle
for getting shot by the fbi
and sent to prison hijacking seems to
have been a bit of a hobby for trapnel
and his mates though
as six years into his stint behind bars
one of his friends took control of a
helicopter
through the time-honored method of
pointing a gun at the pilot
and forcing him to land in the yard of
the prison where trapnum was being held
the boulders you like rescue was never
completed though
as the helicopter's pilot who happened
to be a vietnam vet
managed to get hold of the gun and shoot
the hijacker dead
two years later there would be rescuer's
daughter got in on the hijacking act
too strapping fake dynamite to her body
and taking control of a small commercial
flight
once again demanding the release of
trapnil
that guy sure had some loyal friends
anyway on this occasion fbi agents were
able to talk the girl down
she was only 17 at the time and trapnel
remained behind
bars until his death thanks to this
space of hijackings 1972 was a year the
airline industry was quite happy to put
behind it
and in 1973 the first universal luggage
searches were brought
in which had a dramatic effect on
would-be dbs
only two hijackings were attempted that
year and both the culprits were
psychiatric patients
strangely enough one of the 1973
hijackers
wanted to meet richard nixon too well he
wanted to crash the plane into the white
house and kill him
but i suppose that's kind of the same
thing popular guy was nixon
this trend of cooper fanboy seems to
have died out after that
until 1980 when glenn tripp
hijacked a plane demanding six hundred
thousand dollars
two parachutes and the assassination of
his boss all
whilst completely failing to notice the
flight attendant
had spiked his drink with valium ten
hours later
a distinctly more chilled out trip had
abandoned his original demands
and requested free cheeseburgers instead
tripp was nothing if not persistence
though and three years later while still
on parole
he hijacked the exact same flight
presumably this time he was careful not
to partake
in any free in-flight beverages but
as it happened he had bigger things to
worry about than valium
after demanding to be taken to
afghanistan tripp
was shot and killed by the fbi when the
plane finally touched down in portland
db cooper worship has evolved over the
years
and he's even been turned into a bit of
a folk hero
there are shops and hospitality venues
all over the pacific northwest
you hold regular cooper themed
promotions and sell souvenirs to taurus
not to mention his appearance in lots of
film and on tv
a notable recent documentary hbo's the
mystery of db cooper
adds a few new suspects to the old
favorites
including one woman who suspected her
late husband
and a couple who were convinced cooper
was their transgender friend
barbara mind you that would at least
explain the bee
in his name whoever he was and
wherever he went i think it's fair to
say dan cooper
got away with it and the fbi clearly
agrees
because in july 2016
they finally decided they'd had enough
they effectively did their best eric
cartman impression and said
screw you guys we're going here and
suspended their investigation
into the cooper case and so it looks
like db cooper has taken his place
alongside
jack the ripper the zodiac killer and
the joker
in the pantheon of criminals whose true
identity
will never be revealed over 45 years the
fbi compiled a 60-volume
case file and a 28-part packet of
evidence on cooper's hijacking
but it seems to have done no bloody good
whatsoever
by the way all that information is
available to the general public
so next time you're at fbi headquarters
in washington dc
why not show up wearing a db cooper
t-shirt and
mock them for their failure oh and then
run fast they're usually packing heat
thanks for watching